I think that white people are committed
to being villains. They are so corrupt.
Their thinking is so morally and
spiritually bankrupt about power. That
is spiritually who they are. In a recent
video, we looked at how some American
Muslims, who otherwise live in very
fragile glass houses, like to hurl
stones at Western heroes, namely
Christopher Columbus, whom they condemn
as a mass murderer and slaver.
Meanwhile, such Muslims devoutly ignore
and hope you are unaware of the fact
that Islam's heroes have done far worse,
conquering, massacring, and enslaving
countless millions of people through the
centuries. 80 million Hindus alone, and
all in the name of Islam. Now, to be
sure, this fake history has a very
specific and increasingly deadly agenda.
If you rewrite the past in a manner that
casts all whites and Christians as
villains, and casts all non-whites and
non-Christians as victims, voila,
non-whites begin to hate, despise, and
even seek to, and in fact, kill whites.
Or did you think this growing phenomenon
of black men randomly assaulting and
murdering white people is itself random?
No, they've been repeatedly told and are
responding to the claim that white
people are the source of all evil. They
are, in short, avenging themselves on
their oppressors. For an example of the
sort of intellectual backing that feeds
this hatred, look no further than to
Brittney Cooper, a black professor at
Rutgers University, who, when it comes
to white people, believes that, well,
let's hear it from the horse's mouth. I
think that white people are committed to
being villains in the aggregate, right?
The real sort of issue here, and I, you
know, I've heard people sort of say it,
is
one, I think that white people
viscerally fear. It's not that white
people don't know, right, what they have
done. They know.
They fear that there is no other way to
be human but the way in which they are
human, which is to So, you know, like
you talk to white people, and whenever
you you really want to have a reckoning
about it, they say stuff like, you know,
it's just human nature. If y'all had all
of this power, you would have done the
same thing, right?
>> Right, indeed. In fact, 17 years ago, I
made this very same point about human
nature in an article. Check it out, link
in the description. Look, it really
comes to this. If whites have been
historically aggressive or exploitative
of non-whites, it's not because they are
intrinsically evil, a racist point, by
the way, but simply because they were
able to.
And that's the bottom line of all
history, capability.
Did whites defeat and uproot Native
Americans, enslave Africans, and
colonize brown people because they lived
according to some sort of unprecedented
bellicose creed alien to non-whites?
Quite the contrary. They did so because
they, as opposed to natives, blacks,
etc., were able to do so.
Think about it. If the Native Americans
before Columbus's time were the first to
develop galleys for transoceanic travel,
or advanced firearms, or compasses, or
organized military structures and
stratagems,
and if they had arrived on the shores of
Europe at its weakest point in history,
what would they have done?
Would they have pillaged and plundered,
conquered and subjugated, or would they
have looked at the inferior pale savages
and respected them?
Left them alone in the name of
diversity, human rights, and all that.
What if black Africans were
technologically or militarily more
advanced than their northern neighbors
in Europe during the pre-modern era, and
therefore could have easily subjugated
and enslaved them?
Would they have done so? Or would they
have left them in peace in the name of
multiculturalism? In her rant, Professor
Cooper acknowledges but rejects these
rhetorical questions. they say stuff
like, you know, it's just human nature.
If y'all had all of this power, you
would have done the same thing, right?
And it's like, no, that's what white
humans did. White human beings thought,
there's a world here and we own it.
Prior to them, black and brown people
have been sailing across oceans,
interacting with each other for
centuries without total subjugation,
domination, and colonialism.
>> Not only is this professor's ignorance
profoundly staggering, it is the source
of her desire to take these mofos, that
is, white people, out.
>> I want to say to you is we got to take
these out. BUT I KNOW, BUT
LIKE, WE CAN'T say that, right?
>> After all, in her estimation, and based
on her own words, whites are
intrinsically evil. It's apparently in
their blood. Meanwhile, uh back in the
real world, and as already mentioned,
all peoples, white, black, brown,
yellow, red, have warred on each other,
and when capable, keyword, have gone on
the offensive, often exploiting the
other. Depending on their capabilities,
whether they were, like blacks and
Native Americans, uh limited to bows and
arrows and spears, or whether, like
later Europeans, they possessed guns and
cannons, their impact was either minimal
and local or maximal and global. But the
will to dominate was always there,
across the board. As one author writes,
quote,
"When thinking of pre-Columbian America,
forget what you've seen in the Disney
movies." This is a reference to the 1995
animation Pocahontas.
"Think slavery, cannibalism, and mass
human sacrifice. From the Aztecs to the
Iroquois, that was life among the
indigenous peoples before Columbus
arrived. For all the talk from the angry
and indigenous about European slavery,
it turns out that pre-Columbian America
was virtually one huge slave camp.
Similarly, another author writes that
American Indians engaged in, quote,
total subjugation and domination,
despite Ms. Cooper's insistence that
Prior to them, black and brown people
have been sailing across oceans,
interacting with each other for
centuries without total subjugation,
domination, and colonialism.
>> He adds that, quote, "Many historians
agree that Native American tribes
committed atrocities against each other,
thirsting for power and land, and
killing anyone that stood in the way
long before any European settler set
foot on the continent. Indeed, it was
the same with Professor Cooper's own
African ancestors. They continuously
warred on, slaughtered, and enslaved
each other for eons before whites ever
came to sub-Saharan Africa. Moreover, as
Michael Amalawa, a Nigerian diplomat,
once explained, quote, "The bulk of the
supply of African slaves sold to
Europeans came from the Nigerians. These
Nigerian middlemen moved to the
interior, where they captured other
Nigerians who belonged to other
communities.
Other communities. I wonder if these
Nigerian slavers were the Muslims of
Nigeria, and they were enslaving the
Christians and non-Muslims of the
interior, sort of like is happening
today with the genocide and massacres.
At any rate, he continues, quote, "Many
Nigerian middlemen began to depend
totally on the slave trade and neglected
every other business and occupation. The
result was that when the trade was
abolished by England in 1807, these
Nigerians began to protest. As years
went by and the trade collapsed, such
Nigerians lost their sources of income
and became impoverished. These are not
just historical observations. Although
it was those intrinsically villainous
Christians of Europe who spearheaded the
abolition of slavery around the world,
there are today still more than 50
million slaves, the overwhelming
majority of them in the non-Western
world. In the words of a 2019 report,
quote, "As the world marks 400 years
since the first recorded African slaves
arrived in North America, slavery
remains a modern-day scourge. Africa has
the highest prevalence of slavery, with
more than seven victims for every 1,000
people." None of this, however, seems to
matter to Ms. Cooper. For this
professor, the scourge of slavery,
indeed, any and every social ill, begins
and ends with whites and therefore
inherently evil people. Hence, the need
to
>> We got to take these out.
BUT I KNOW, BUT LIKE, WE CAN'T SAY THAT,
RIGHT?
>> SO, there it is. The next time a person
of color randomly assaults or kills a
white person, know that there is nothing
random about it. Rather, this is the
inevitable byproduct of an especially
pernicious and very racist form of fake
history, one that maintains that whites,
which also means Christians, as all
whites were historically Christian in
the eras we are discussing, are
intrinsically villainous, whereas
everyone else, black, brown, yellow, and
red, are intrinsically virtuous. Until
such time that this fake history is
corrected, that is, eliminated and
supplanted by true history, expect much
more resentment, ill will, hatred, and,
of course, bloodshed.
[Music]